[Musique]
salut bonjour
alors là mon cap je vais rencontrer
n'accueillons familiale de la belle
ville de saint joseph sabrina compagne
chez elles des personnes en situation de
handicap sur vos projets pour les sortir
de l'isolément bien sûr et d'ailleurs on
va le voir c'est une vocation première
depuis cinq ans on va en discuter avec
elle alexandre nous les saluons tout à
l'heure ok
si vous aussi vous voulez en savoir un
peu plus sur l'accueil familial à
domicile était avec moi
[Musique]
nous sommes à saint joseph chez sabrina
le breton cela fait cinq ans qu'elle
accueille à son domicile des personnes
en situation de handicap c'est un
travail quotidien mais c'est surtout une
mission qui lui tient à coeur grâce à
l'agrément du département sabrina peu
depuis 2010 est remplir pleinement
heureux de familles d'accueil allons
discuter avec m
la cliente familiale ou accueil chez o2
personnes en situation de handicap au
delà d'un toit et doute présence que les
très importantes qu importe maintenant
il n'a pas été une aide dans la vie
quotidienne que ce soit pour la toilette
les repas
les sorties
là les accompagnements lors des
différents déplacements chez les
spécialistes et cinq ans maintenant que
les accords de famille donne quelles
sont les démarches qu'on l'a fait pour
devenir justement accueillant le tram il
a alors envoyé un courrier au
département de saint denis et moi
l'expression de mon souhait d'être
travailleur familial et à ce moment là
ça m'a envoyé moi tous les documents
nécessaires
mal était profond qu'il soit sa pierre
pour une réunion et c'est de là que tout
a démarré visiter psychologue visites à
domicile qui est de l'assistance sociale
puis la formation initiale que les très
très important merci tu as we know
sabrina fait partie de ces particuliers
qui peuvent accueillir chez eux des
personnes en situation de handicap elle
est accompagnée dans cette mission par
les agents du département qui sont
constamment à son équipe et la compagne
pour lui permettre d'offrir le meilleur
cadre possible assez accueilli laurie
assistant social au sein de la direction
d'autonomie ban aux enchères d'ici
laurie bonjour bonjour le risque est ce
que l'accueil familial donc alors
l'accueil familial ça me d'hébergement
alternatif entre le maintien à domicile
et l'accueil en hébergement donc alors
l'agrément il est délivré pour une
période de cinq ans et tout au long de
ces cinq ans la cliente participent à
des formations la clientèle peut être
agréé pour l'accueil d'une deux ou trois
personnes à temps complet ou à temps
partiel l'accueil familial est destiné à
l'accueil de personnes âgées ou adultes
en situation de handicap qui ne veulent
plus ou ne peuvent plus vivre à l'heure
de nice nous sommes d'accord comment
devient ton justement accueillante
rigole donc alors pour devenir
accueillant familial la personne envoyé
une demande par courrier ou département
à la suite de ça on va venir sur place à
son domicile pour évaluer un petit peu
les différentes conditions et quelles
sont les conditions à réunir justement
pour devenir un clan familial dans un
premier temps il faut être majeur donc
on soit en couple seul on peut faire la
demande d'agrément par la suite on va
venir nous au domicile s'assurer qu'une
nouvelle conditions de logement tout est
réuni nombreux s'y prend l'enfant de
l'environnement familial et la façon de
vivre de la famille d'accord mais à ses
lauriers merci
c'est une vraie relation de confiance
qui se fait entre les accueillants et le
département ces échanges mensuels
permettent à sabrina et jon particulier
de veiller sur le bien-être de leur
accueil
si vous souhaitez avoir plus
d'informations sur l'accueil familial
n'hésitez pas vous avez toutes les
coordonnées qui s'affiche sur votre
écran et c'est déjà la fin du
département les générations si vous
souhaitez vous voir cet épisode ainsi
que les épisodes précédents rendez vous
sur le site elodie l'eau sociaux quant à
moi je vous retrouve très vite par
nouvel épisode à bientôt
[Musique]
la semaine prochaine je vous amène à la
cellule insertion de saint paul où nous
rencontrerons tristan qui a bénéficié du
fond d'oeil aux jeunes une aide
financière du département qui s'adresse
aux jeunes ayant des difficultés
matérielles pour favoriser leur
insertion sociale et professionnelle
[Musique]